[Music]
cool moms take daughters clothes bad
moms take their identity laura oglesby
impersonated her estranged daughter who
was in her early 20s at the time
in 2016 she applied for a social
security card and then used it to get a
driver's license
for two years oglesby lived like any
other young adult enrolled in university
took out student loans dated young men
everybody believed it she even had
boyfriends that believed that she was
that age 22 years old
she also received 9 400 in federal
student loans
5 920 in pell grants
337 for books and thousand eight hundred
and sixty three dollars in finance
charges and now it's time to behave like
an adult ogilvy already pleaded guilty
to social security fraud and is facing
up to five years in prison without
parole because i know life sucks